[Music]
all right quite a crowd here tonight
thank you all for being here and um let
me just start by saying it's such a
beautiful film thank you for making it
thank you for sharing it with us tonight
and thank you for coming all this way to
talk about it thank you
[Music]
god
your buddy from belfast where everybody
knows you
hey
[Music]
we're looking to cleanse the community
away but you wouldn't want to be the old
man out in the street
talk to my family and i'll kill you
so we're gonna have to leave belfast
we'll fight this together
this is what this is war
we're living in a civil war
what do you want
i want my family with me
kenneth to kick things off i i read
recently that you wrote the script in a
very short period of time
um during the pandemic could you talk
about the
just
how long you've been working on this how
long the writing process was uh i will
and thank you and thanks everybody for
coming tonight we appreciate it um the
um
i guess the the writing process was
about um
eight weeks and 50 years
um
uh
i'd wanted to write something about
belfast for a long time had made many
notes over over many decades and then
the the introspection and the silence at
the beginning of this lockdown uh sent
me back to another lockdown which was
the one that we
experienced at that time
and
it was one of those things that sort of
uh poured out and um and
then it gathered a momentum of its own i
showed it to my brother and sister who
were the two people who i
wanted to um read it first as they were
the first two people to see the film in
its finish form and really it depended
on them being happy that we were writing
about a version a version of events
inspired by what our family went through
uh and then the momentum into making the
film and meeting up with all these
amazing people followed thereafter
so i i've read um
in several of the reviews i've read it
refers to this as being
semi-autobiographical and i don't know
if that's a term that you would use but
um well i just think inevitably at a
distance of 50 years and when you
deliberately uh set out to sort of
look from a the point of view of
a nine-year-old i think that there will
be not necessarily a documentary kind of
truth but you hope there'd be an
emotional truth and also there was a
desire not to make it merely
um you know
personal therapy or a sort of you know
sort of recreation of specific events
but hopefully begin with something that
could open itself up to
do what we've been thrilled to hear in
lots of cases the film has done which is
to open up
the individual
audience members to thoughts of their
own childhood and
and related kind of events so so to be
not literal
um
and be semi autobiographical maybe
allows for that to happen more
you know
when i heard about the film i for some
reason deliberately chose not to read
any much about it at all and when i saw
the film
um
i went in not knowing what to expect and
when i saw it i was
so surprised by
this is a
an approach to you know the the troubles
in belfast at that time that i've never
seen portrayed on screen before
and the the warmth of the family and
that's the center
the core of the family um
you know they're living through that
sectarian violence and and all the
political context but it's really a
story of this family that is so powerful
well it certainly that seemed to be the
center of it and and and on both you
know kieran and and jamie without
talking on their behalf were aware of of
what also the belfast version of that
was often characterized by which is you
know passion and and and humor as well a
very particular belfast sense of humor
i i'd love to hear from the cast about
um
jamie and katrina maybe you could start
talking about
how how you created your relationship
um
once you were on set and and
diving into this because the the
relationships in this family are so
strong and powerful
and you know there's warmth and humor
and
um so many nuances to to your
performances if you could just talk a
bit about
how you when you got involved and how
you how you created that marriage um i
was involved before katrina so i didn't
know when when i got um
involved in it i didn't know it was
going to be katrina um
i'm going to give
ken a lot of credit for
you know considering and um
understanding and and hoping that we'd
be a good match together based on uh
meeting us
and then it's one of those things where
we really just
hit it off um
katrina
is one of if not the easiest person i've
ever worked with
um
we were thrust into this uncomfortable
um
the first time we met
was a dance rehearsal
and if anything's going to bring
two people who can't dance very well
together
it is trying to teach them how to dance
so um i think we bonded pretty quickly
over over our um
lack of ability our amazing uh
coordination yeah
um well no i just think well so much of
the relationship was on the page you
know i think when it's written so well
like that
so much of your work is done
um but it was it was really organic i
mean i think you know we we had this
beautiful day one of the first days as
well where ken got
um
[Music]
kieron jamie and myself in a room and we
all just sat around and talked about you
know ken was very clever in the
questions he was asking us about you
know our childhoods our parents you know
how different things would have gone in
our lives and and i think that that also
broke down barriers very quickly and we
sort of all bonded from that and
you know i think yeah it was very
instantaneous i mean jamie and i have a
weirdly a very similar trajectory even
though we've never really met and
um i don't know we just have a lot of
things in common so it's just very
easy
the
the rehearsal for the dancing was that
for the
uh
the wake sequence was that
yeah that because that scene is amazing
i mean the
i mean i'd love to hear you talk about
that as well because it almost felt
was that the wake following
the death of
well it was many you may have some
experiences yourself but it was many
experiences
we had sorry whoops of um
yeah the the the you know the the yin
and yang that says the celebratory
lunacy of uh
especially after my own father slept in
the same room as
his father for the five five days and
nights that he was laid out as everybody
came to see him and i think by the time
that was all over you really needed to
let some steam off you know and so
singing and dancing were would
definitely uh yeah okay it's a beautiful
scene
um
jude i'd love to hear
if you would talk about how you got into
this film what how you learned about it
what the audition process was like
well i remember initially i
sent her a self tape just a normal self
tip
and
once i got call backed i find out who
would be writing it and directing it
and i ran about my house for about five
minutes screaming
and
just the chance to work with all of
these actors is just
amazing and
as my film debut this is just amazing
and really really lucky
and yeah it was a few callbacks and
in the
last callback actually that was the
first time i ever met ken
and he was such a lovely
down-to-earth person
that you could sit down and make friends
with maybe not talk about football
though because he supports tottenham
excellent
i think we should just ask him all the
questions i think we should i think
y'all can just roll back a few yeah
um
no but jude actually if you could talk a
little bit more about your experience
filming um this was
this wasn't your first time
on a film set i don't believe but it was
one of the first
am i right uh this was the first this
was the first okay first
so
amazing
so
okay well
kenneth if you could talk more i mean i
asked the question about how you you
know the centrality of this family and
the relationships but could you talk a
bit as as a director sort of
what do you try to foster on what is the
how do you try and create the onset
experience for your actors because i
mean you've directed so many great films
with
always with incredibly strong
performances and i'm just curious
was your approach here similar to how
you worked on other films or did you
approach this differently in what you
were building on on set for well i think
you try to
um find uh the way whatever the way is
for that particular project and this
particular group of actors
who are very very open so i mean a
specific example with this one who was
very kind uh judy dench uh her
eyesight's not terribly good and
we provided her with a copy of the the
newspaper that she reads as the
character it's called the people's
friend and it's a religious journal but
it's mainly full of sort of mills and
boons romantic stories about um you know
in
carrying torches for doctors who don't
realize their lodger is in love with
them etc and
kieran do you remember this
in lieu of judy's failing eyes
read
a story from the people's friend to judy
in rehearsal sort of across a crowded
room
um and it was a magical moment because
it was like a it was as if we'd
instantly shifted into their
relationship um and she was listening
you read it ever so well
thank you very much
and
did you talk about that
but i think it's got to do with the way
that uh ken very quickly and very
astutely brought us all together and
says
katrina was saying you know within an
hour of us all meeting each other at
four ends of a very wide long table
we kind of all knew each other's
childhood
and therefore we were open enough to
know where we all came from and
therefore what ken i think was using it
for was for us to be open enough to to
use our knowledge of each other's
childhood to be able to connect
instantly with the person that you want
to do and for judy and i it was great
because we had never met and
she she was
she is such a
dynamo i mean she's really her instinct
is extraordinary and
her ability to turn the sixpence i know
ken knows that they've worked together
so long but uh
for us to think into
believing that we had already had 50
years of marriage together
the preparation the very quick and
astute preparation that ken kind of
suggested we go for was ultimately
hugely useful for the work we had to do
the other thing i say though uh which
kieran the others won't is that that
that's really only possible if that
group of actors are generous enough to
do that because obviously it's a very
vulnerable thing you don't know people
and maybe you don't want to tell them
things that are quite
sort of personal to you and there was a
great deal of generosity and i think
once you see that that's happening you
kind of all hold hands together and and
also acknowledge gosh that that is going
to be part of the dna of this piece so
when for me it was a big thrill i went
home feeling uh that there was a a big
heart
a big communal heart beating beating in
that rehearsal room and it was because
they were ready to um you know
generously but unsurely give of
themselves
i mean
whatever you did in that process was
fully manifest on the screen because i
felt like i was living with that family
and just
immediately drawn in and uh
you know the film unfolds at a
the the pacing of the film is
interesting it's not rushed or overly
dramatic but these you know there's a
steady build of progression of events of
like what's going to happen are they
going to have to move
how it's affecting buddy i mean it's you
know every little emotional nuance is
there on the screen
i was just sorry i didn't live long
enough to attend my own wake because
i seem fantastic
it was amazing there was a horn section
[Laughter]
them were angels
um
kenneth could you talk a bit about the
decision to shoot in black and white and
also to have that initial burst of color
at the beginning
um
jamie dornan and katrina belf both rang
me and said we think we both look even
more beautiful in black and white and uh
and we and we insist we insist that we
are photographed in black and white i
think that was it wasn't it it was your
agents to begin with and then it was
youtube um
the uh it was to do with uh feeling that
uh you know that curious thing with
black and white when people use that
phrase it's all there in black and white
as if it's additionally authentic to
have that even though it's not how we
see the world um for me it has this
paradox of being sort of um
forensic you know you look because
there's less color to look at harris our
cinematographer said color describes
people and black and white lets you feel
people and somehow this poetic dimension
to something that was also producing a
very sort of authentic quality the kind
of quality that you might see in a in a
great reportage photograph we were sort
of after as well but um we also wanted
color to be about the belfast that is
now
uh and also color to be about the
imagination of of buddy as the cinemas
from this neck of the woods uh explode
uh in his mind uh but i do think
everybody looks better in black and
white to be honest um and uh there's a
there's a there's a
uh
a wonderful sort of uh
you know monochromatic palette that is
beautiful uh
jamie often tells me it always was sunny
when he was growing up in belfast it was
always raining what about you kieran
what was the weather like when you were
growing up always raining
so black and white
um the the bursts of color you alluded
to in the middle of the film when a
chili chi bang bang and things like that
really
i felt like this film was also a love
letter to cinema like i was imagining
this was
this piece i assume is autobiographical
that you saw those films as a child
growing up in belfast yeah and we had
now
hey jude had you had you ever seen
chitty chitty bang bang before we showed
it to you on the set
um
i've seen clips of it before but i
haven't watched the full film though
and jamie and katrina had you seen it
because one of one of the pleasures i
had when we were shooting that was
trying to i tried to withhold the pieces
from you as
as much as possible have you seen either
of those films or uh chitty chibang or a
million years bc
definitely chitty chitty bang bang but i
hadn't not the other one yeah chili
chili bang bang big favorite in my house
i hadn't seen
a million years
no i should though looks
that's good
um so with the decision to shoot you so
obviously you were filming this during
the pandemic and operating under
pandemic conditions so um before we came
out you were telling me that that was a
constructed set the the street that they
lived on was completely built
um
so can you talk a bit about just
uh
whatever you care to share about the
challenges of shooting under covet were
there things that you enjoyed about it
that were
enhanced the experience for you or was
it just you had to just deal with like
practical limitations for health and
safety uh i think you know uh free
freedom means having no choice so we had
no choice and uh there was a freedom to
do with uh the building up of some
family feeling that was
you know partly because
these guys were all in a bubble um
and then there was a certain kind of uh
quiet ritual um
you know the props folk would go in
first and then they'd come out of the
set and then the electrics would go in
and then they'd come out and then the
actors would arrive there'd be very few
people um and although it was true of
belfast whenever the sun did shine we
did open the windows and you know let
the air in
all of the windows in that are open in
this film are partly to do with airflow
and covet regulations so so anytime we
anytime we could get the windows open we
did the weather
satisfied us in that regard as well but
everybody had to test every day
everybody tested for two weeks before
they came in um and uh
i do how did it feel to you was there
something about the the routine of that
that was scary i know as a sort of with
my producer hat on it was pretty sweaty
every morning when the test came in how
did how was it how was it for you guys
the covet of it all i mean it's one of
those things you you know i think very
quickly it becomes just routine but i do
think
there is again that kind of
bonding thing that happens because of it
you know even with all of our crew who
were absolutely amazing
um you know because it was such a small
group of us i think we all got to know
each other very well and
i think it it adds i don't know there
was that kind of we were the only i
think it was us and batman right we're
the only two films up so there was sort
of a
pioneering quality to it too
yeah and and sort of gratitude sense of
gratitude and privilege and sort of the
preciousness of being able to do it i
did think uh we we had if you recall we
gave we gave first jobs to about 10
drama students who had their first had
their first professional work on this
and they'd been you know they had no you
know they'd no necessarily prospect of
doing anything so that energy coming
onto the set was also
amazing as a as as was
you know 85 year old judy denches who
was thrilled to be back and working and
and
and bringing that kind of
energy her late husband michael williams
used to say the the problem with judy is
every day is christmas bloody morning
[Laughter]
katrina um i wonder if you could talk a
bit about your
role i
i i mean the whole family dynamic is so
powerful and everybody's connected but i
felt like you were the
beating heart of this family and you
know coming to that painful dis at the
scene when you finally decide it's time
to go was was so powerful
um
anything you'd care to share about sort
of how you approached that
moment and
well the thing about ma which i loved so
much is that
in her little street in her little
community she is
so
confident in herself and knows who she
is but anything beyond that is is
totally beyond her comprehension and she
becomes a little child even thinking
about it
and
you know it was that thing of being them
you know she wanted to protect her
children but for her the only way she
knew how was in this street where she
knew
and it took her so long to sort of get
to the point where she realized that
you know she had to step outside of
herself for the for the good of her kids
um
you know i i
in preparation for this role i
i watched so many interviews of women
from belfast and women from the north
who
talked about
you know how they were holding families
together during this time or struggling
against that and
you know as as an irish woman
it was so emotional watching all of
these stories like they
i mean we we represent men very well in
this film and and show the beautiful
side and their softness but
for a lot of women in the north they
were really
they had to sort of hold down the fort
when these horrible things were going on
around them and they carried the weight
of what was going on
i think
you know more
and especially in terms of the families
and so i just yeah i just wanted to
show that and to sort of honor those
women and
um
[Music]
yeah
another scene where what you were just
talking about really comes here is when
you march buddy back to the grocery
store to return the detergent like that
was you're taking him through like kind
of a terrifying situation but he's gonna
return that damn soap that was such a
great scene to film it was so good i
mean we
this one was buzzing for days afterwards
um
like that
yeah you know i i definitely
we had uh the screening on thursday and
my mom was in the audience and and i
kind of said you know there's a lot of
my mom in that performance and then i
felt really bad i was like that i was uh
you know i think there's a ferocity to
irish irish mommies um you know they
they love you fiercely but they will
they will give you a clip in the ear if
you step out of line so
um it's great i mean you know that it's
just that that passion and that love and
it's like
it's with fear as well you know you
don't want anything to happen to them so
it's that tough love that comes through
jamie i wanted to ask you about one
moment in the film when you're talking
to buddy um it's late in the film where
you basically he's you know realizing
he's gonna be away from the girl that
he's interested in and you say and that
and he he references that she's catholic
and you say well
there's no issues as long as people are
kind and
good and decent it doesn't matter what
tribe you come from and i felt like that
really was
the point of view of the film and and
also of you in that moment it's a
beautiful moment between you and jude
um
i'm not sure if the question is for you
or for kenneth but that sentiment um
uh feels like it drives the film and
it's it's a it's a very hopeful sort of
i mean i think there's definitely
something in that what you said there
about being
one of the messages that's within the
film um
if you can get people thinking along
those lines more in that part of the
world it'd be a very good thing but i
think that applies to
any division in any part of the world
you know if you can
find acceptance and respect
for the other side or what are deemed to
be the other side then that's the only
way you're going to solve any of these
problems
so
it was
lovely to be able to play that scene
um
i very fortunately was brought up that
way where there wasn't enough in them in
in my household or in any of my way of
thinking or the community i grew up in
so
to be able to impart that to uh my
pretend son
in in the movie was was important to me
and i think it's important that that
message is in in the film
yeah
um
at that moment the film feels you know
it's 1969 belfast but it felt very
contemporary to me to it feels like the
film speaks to the moment that we're in
right now both in terms of the sense of
lockdown but also that
uh
you know we are factionalized and
we are in different tribes and there's a
you know i don't know if that was
animating your desire to make this film
at this time
were you were you thinking about that at
all as you know the moment that we're
living in right now politically or
culturally
i i think uh i think probably
inevitably
i think
it it's uh
when um
billy clanton says uh you know i'll keep
it simple you're either with us or
you're against us
uh that's a i think that's a that's uh
i understand where it comes from but
it's not it's not a civilized way to run
a society i don't think you have to
there's so many
different there's so many layers and
gray areas between
strong positions held by people who may
oppose each other and although it is
very difficult it is very difficult
there's no question about that the
necessity for
understanding has never been greater and
of course the understanding is hard work
you know you have to you have to sort of
not be entrenched and
you know you have to accept that a
passionate point of view need not be
undermined by listening to another
passionate point of view and and
considering in fact your passionate
point of view might be enriched by that
it's all easy to say it's hard to do
um
and so uh inevitably you were talking
about this as well weren't you just the
the
just the the other night the the
yeah the the tribalism our version of
tribalism yeah we i mean
the peace process in the north of
ireland northern ireland happened in 97
i think was the good friday agreement
and
it was a long long time coming
and uh
jbt we would all i guess be supporters
of integrated education
in the north of ireland so because we
have a system whereby
uh church and state at the ages of four
kids go to different schools and it's
something that's very important to
us that integrated education becomes a
major force
in the healing
of what's happened in the province of
the northern ireland and uh
it just makes complete sense because
people as we know aren't born with
racism or hatred or sectarianism and
it's informed and the idea is once you
leave them to yourself and they share
ideas they can make them make their own
mind up and it won't be as divisive as
the culture that we have come from and
now we're
24 years on down the line
and there's still a lot of work to do
there's still a lot of work to do and we
recognize that and there are a lot of
good people at home
a lot of good people still working to
heal the divisions and go out into the
different communities and get them
together but
this rift runs deep and
so the only hope is that we can keep
pushing forward with positive agendas
and keep trying to connect with each
other
[Applause]
and i i also want to ask you kenneth
about the music in the film it's it's
van morrison start to finish and both
older songs but he composed things for
the film as well could you talk about
the experience of working with him on
the film it's i mean it's a fantastic
score and um well thank you i mean he's
a great artist um he uh when i was uh to
the age that judy's in the film uh he
just
he spent it seemed to did like two years
almost in in right at the top of the
charts with a
revolutionary album in astral week so he
was a big he's a big hero
to us
um
i approached him about this uh nervously
um did a sort of uh telephonic audition
uh with him in which the apparently
famously grumpy uh van uh sort of
ran his eye over his ear over me but he
was not remotely grumpy he was very he
was very engaged with the story about uh
you know leaving ireland and being away
he seems as though that spoke to him um
but of course he has the soul of belfast
in him you know and he has this uh
orchestra of a voice
and deep deep deep musicality incredible
gift for melody and atmosphere and mood
and depth
and and depth brought to the popular
song if you like so when he when he
sings
carrick fergus accompanied by the
chieftains just a harp and his voice
as as the father says cheerio to the to
the boy it's a it's a he he brings a
level of depth and and soul to that that
is uh transformative and transcendent so
he was
a major addition he wrote all of the
mood music the saxophone
music um
in response to the script he came to
cuts of the film and he offered
suggestions for
um sort of arrangement changes that were
sensitive to the film and generally was
a
an immense
ally and we were very thrilled to see
him there we
played the film on thursday of last week
in belfast first night at the belfast
film festival it was a hell of a night
for us um and he was there and we were
all there and
the music
really sang
beautiful beautiful
well
i could keep talking to you for so much
longer but i am getting the signal i
think the time has come
thank you all so much for being here
and um i do have one last question for
jude uh
having wrapped the film what do you
think are you going to keep going with
this
101
excellent
thank you all so much
[Music]
you